il a rendu notre base aérienne il a
rendu nos armes il a rendu
notre ambassade
ils ont dépensé un milliard de dollars pour construire
cette ambassade ridicule
et il a abandonné nos grands
citoyens américains ils sont finis en ce moment ils
n'ont aucune idée rappelez-vous que les talibans sont
durs
et ils ne respectent pas  notre pays et
ils ne respectent pas notre président ce n'est
pas bon
ils sont là-bas maintenant et ils ne
savent pas ce qui va se passer nos citoyens
joe biden partaient
en vacances alors
que l'afghanistan allait en enfer
[Applaudissements]
et c'est ce qui  vous obtenez quand vous avez une
faiblesse dans la maison blanche vous ne pouvez pas
avoir de faiblesse dans la maison blanche ils
doivent respecter votre président quand
j'étais président
nous n'avions que de la force ce que nous avons fait comment
nous nous sommes retrouvés dans ce gâchis est tout simplement incroyable
mais nous  aurait pu sortir avec honneur
et nous aurions dû sortir avec honneur
et à la place
nous sommes sortis avec l'exact opposé de l'
honneur
[Musique]